[Applause]
hello everyone and hello for French
people I'm gonna I'm not going to talk
about sooth package manager today
actually sorry for the clickbait about
relationship and all that I'm going to
talk about dependence resolution
actually and how it works how we solve
that problem in sooth package manager
and listen this with SPM I'm gonna say
SPM because close friends I'm gonna say
SPM changed its resolver recently to pub
grub it's a different algorithm for
dependence resolution and a real quick
word about pop group it's a algorithm
quite new it's been two years three
years it's me it's around and it's
device originally for dart program
language and it has some advantages over
other algorithms that's why it's getting
popular and popular among the package
browsers and I'm gonna try to explain
how pop lock works and how am I gonna do
that
first I'm gonna define the problem what
is the problem depends resolution why is
this a problem why do we need that then
I'm going to introduce the basics of pub
grub then I'm gonna show you a real
world example case and then I'm gonna
end with the big classic so let's start
with the problem and in our Swiss
projects we have package outs with file
where we declare our package and it's
dependencies but we usually give version
ranges instead of exact version numbers
so that means package manager needs to
come and resolve these ranges into exact
versions and this is the problem going
from package dot Swift to package all
resolved but it's not an easy problem
it's a hard it's an np-hard problem
because there is no straight line
between those two actually solution is
much more complicated somewhere like now
it's it's somewhere you cannot see where
you're going clearly you cannot find the
exit easily so I can you have an idea
but I'm gonna show you it's a bit like
this actually
and it's a band it's a maze actually and
okay for the international audience I
need to explain it and you know VIN
right VIN textile turbine okay
shuttle oil is the beam of Paris Metro
you cannot you cannot so yeah let's move
on now we have a maze in the maze we
make decisions and we try to find the
right combination of decisions to find
where I find our way out sometimes we
hit dead ends which means conflicts in
our case when we hit a dead end we need
to go back to the decision and we need
to try a different path until we find
our way out that's what we're gonna
basically do here and we can find we can
solve this problem by trying every
possible combination blindly but can we
do better let's see let's see how pub
grub works how popular improves the
solution at a very high level popular up
those two main things first it learns it
learns about the maze as it advances in
the maze it learns the facts it
remembers the causes and actions
basically to create a map of the maze so
when it hits a dead end it instantly
know knows where to go back to take a
different path and it's also smart it's
smart enough to take lessons from the
mistakes so it doesn't repeat the same
mistake again and again ok
and that's also I need to explain that
and I have no analogy for m13 it's like
no other but I can give you a trivia
actually because people don't know about
this but m13 was built as a tool to try
out different compression algorithms
it's a compression tool it takes two
thousand people compresses into one
single carriage of metro and then it
didn't work out they puted they change
business model they become a metro but
it's originally it's a compression tool
anyway anyway when I say smart I mean
it's not like AI or machine learning
smart it's not it doesn't use ball chain
it's just logically pure logically smart
what do I mean - I'm going to show you a
little simple logic trick here that's a
logical expression a or X and B or not X
ok let's think about it if X is true the
first part becomes true automatically
and we depend on B for this expression
to be true and if X is false second part
becomes true and we depend on a for this
expression to be true right so what I
can do is I can reduce I can resolve
this whole expression into simply a or B
right so what does it give me why do I
need this
let's see in the Pablos public's case in
Pablo if you have a dependence like that
Bandra version one depends on John's
version one if I represent this
constraint as a dependency I need to say
van Buuren one and John's version one
must be my solution at the same time but
that judgment and statement itself or
statement and I need all statements to
do this trick dispositive I forgot to
tell you sorry and so that dependency
doesn't work for me that dependence
model doesn't work for me so what I need
to do is I can go to I can flip it
around I can look at incompatible
versions and I can say that if band
version one depends on John's version
one I can say van rooijen one is
incompatible with all the other versions
of terms right right sorry so what does
give me if I model this constraint in
that way I can say that van rooijen one
and not John's version one can not be in
my solution at the same time and if I
rewrite this expression
it gives me or expression right so why
is this important because let's say
John's version one also depends on
guitar version one another and another
depends the another package and it's
this transitive dependency is implicit
now but if I write this constraint in
the same form not terms we want or
guitar we want I can I think you see
where it goes right okay I'm gonna give
you a little push again but okay now X
becomes drums and I
do my magic and I can just resolve these
two expressions into one and I can make
this implicit transitive dependency and
explicit dependency that's why in pub
grub
we represent dependencies in the form of
incompatible DS right okay
I just explained how we represent
dependencies and constraints in pub grub
so let me show you a real world example
case in this example chase we're gonna
see a I think the first draft must be
the first dress I don't know it's info I
know this this tune is that I see that
ggressive gave up almost right but you
cannot know this song because it's a new
song from our new album are you have an
album yeah it's it came out yesterday
you cannot know it you have an album I
didn't tell you no actually I'm gonna
show you something cool okay
no but the most boring anyways look and
resolve in identifiers I'm sure that's
us he's gonna be oh nice that's my band
yeah and okay let me show you the
history it's you it's you younger right
with more video that's our first album
gluten free K and it was a huge success
but you know success brings fame fame
brings problems it's you know hard to
deal with
then we starting yoga and meditation to
overcome and weed is so hard but so so
hard and it became a theme for our
second album namaste we open our third
eye actually right
and I told you about the problems we try
to avoid talking to press about the
problems but I think it's time to face
it yes
so I'm gonna tell you about the problems
but first I need to introduce the band
members this is Maynard one-and-only
our vocals great guy Adam Justin and
that's me and one day our band manager
came to us he said you're a good drummer
or kdrama but I found a better drummer
which is play which plays better than
you so I said ok I'm ok drummer I have
to accept and the problem is this guy
Lars wants to play with Maynard Maynard
wants to play with me you look confused
yeah you can switch the language yeah
I'm gonna let me switch the language
quickly here in in Snyder better it's
its face with this but you know I'm I
support biodiversity I protect
endangered species so I want to protect
object you see people in the audience I
want to change the Swift and I'm gonna
show you this diagram what we have is we
have a band which depends on drums any
version of drums either me or John will
version 2 which is lost so we don't care
but the problem is John's version - Lars
depends on Maynard Walker's version 1
and walkers version 1 depends on me
John's version 1 so at that moment I
said cans with package manager resolve
the conflicts in my relationship and I
said why not let's try so that's
basically it
that's the problem and we have our mains
again what we're gonna do is at every
step we're gonna look around we're gonna
learn about the maze then we're gonna
try to make derivations with what we
learned and if we can not do any of
these we're gonna make a decision to
keep going so let's start what we need
is a drummer so first we enter the maze
we come to a junction and then we look
around we look around and we see two
options we see drum surgeon one John's
version two
and we see there's no dependency on jobs
origin one so it's safe it's okay and we
see a dependency on the side of John's
version two which is an incompatibility
in proverbs language so I learned about
this constraint I take it I keep it in
my pocket and now I need I try to make a
derivation but I cannot because I do not
have enough information about the mains
so now I need to make a decision between
jobs version 2 and ROM version 1 sadly
for me we choose John's version 2
because you know better faster stronger
then we have John's version 2 in our
solution so now I can make the
derivation because I had this
incompatibility and I had this decision
so when I merged when I use them to make
a derivation I can derive that locos
version 1 must be my solution otherwise
I'm gonna have a conflict because of
this incompatibility so I take the
vocals version 1 to my solution and I go
ahead but Walker's version 1 brings its
own incompatibility and that gives me a
dead end because look what what happened
it the terms of this incompatibility are
satisfied by the other terms in my
solution vocals version 1 is satisfied
by the derivation vocals were sorry
drums yeah vocals Washington is
satisfied by the derivation walkers
version 1 and not John's regime one is
satisfied by the decision John's version
2 because John's version 2 is contained
by not drums version one subset and what
I need to do is I need to go back to the
last decision before the root cause and
I then I need to merge the conflict
incompatibility conflicting
compatibility with the root cause and
then I'm gonna try again so I can find
the root cause easily because as I said
pop grab learns everything and remembers
all the causes actions and it creates a
map so it has this graph but what's
satisfied by what and what's caused by
what so I can easily find root cause
I also have my conflicted
incompatibility so I can merge these two
with that logic check we saw earlier and
what I have is I I just learned
something new I had two
incompatibilities they give in a way
they give birth to a third one I learned
something new out of two existing
existing incompatibilities and what does
that mean basically that means drums
version one and any other version but we
one of drums cannot be in my solution at
the same time that basically means if I
choose drums vv2
by automatically have a conflict because
not drums v1 is satisfied instantly in
instantaneously so I can normalize this
incompatibility into simply drums v2 so
I just learned something new I know
where to go back so now I go back to
that to that point in my mace and now
I'm gonna make another derivation thanks
to this new incompatibility so now I can
derive I cannot choose drums v2 so I
need to choose anything but Jones v2 so
thanks to that derivation now I make
another decision and I make Jones week 2
decision and now I can see all the
dependencies are satisfied and now we
can go back playing and we can have fun
with our fans fans you know and that's
good for you yeah yeah yeah that's a
happy ending
actually that's a happy ending and
that's basically how public works and
you may ask why I told all these things
but actually I'm not talking about pub
grub I'm mostly talking about the
mindset we have are we have sweet
package manager we have swift it's all
open source there are a lot of hidden
gems there for example I talked about
popular but there's also like digital
implementation in Swift we can look up
there are a lot of very interesting but
underappreciated problems and solutions
in those open source repo so what I'm
trying to say basically is just go there
be curious learn about these things just
for pure joy of learning that's how did
you learn about that well actually how I
learned about it I was trying to find
out you have a problem with the band and
you needed to resolve yeah because of
last guy yeah this this guy can play for
for but nothing else but yeah
no seriously level blog post I did you
had to to go into the code and yeah I
knew this year is gonna be Swift you a
year so I knew I had to make it told not
about 50 I so I my target was SPM and
okay let me give it in perspective I
need to put that in perspective let's
say if Swift UI is named our great star
player a lot of problems if let's say
catalyst is like like Benzema good
player but controversial and I think SPM
becomes Angola country in this case
underappreciated top performer
consistent great guy but only
appreciated so I think we should we
should we should give our appreciation
to SPM
thanks for trying to do thank you that's
all thank you thanks everyone
[Applause]